un tanque ucraniano acelera a lo largo
de este camino rural abriéndose paso a
toda prisa por la región de gerson en
esta zona del frente sur el enemigo no
se ve por ningún lado lo que significa
que cualquier avance a través de la
maleza podría pasar desapercibido este
soldado ucraniano muestra su trofeo de
guerra un temible lanzacohetes Ruso
apodado huracán
el hecho de que dejaran proyectiles y
esparcieran parte de la pólvora para que
no pudiéramos usarla demuestra que
huyeron rápidamente
estas tropas están decididas a llegar a
la gran ciudad de gerson para Navidad ha
sido ocupada desde principios de marzo
kiev anunció el miércoles que otras
cinco localidades habían sido liberadas
en esta región que Moscú reclama
ilegalmente a ver anexionado en otras
partes del este el frente de batalla del
nombas se ha movido poco en los últimos
días tras un mes de reveses militares
para del ejército de Moscú estos
soldados rusos están convencidos de que
los últimos bombardeos en toda Ucrania
andes moralizado al enemigo
s
es más difícil para ellos que para
nosotros ahora es más difícil para ellos
después de los ataques nuestra moral ha
aumentado mucho los chicos quieren
entrar en combate y terminar esta
operación militar lo antes posible
pero al final del conflicto parece
lejano para estos residentes en la línea
del frente aquí los disparos ucranianos
son frecuentes por lo que condenar los
ataques rusos está fuera del lugar
no me alegro son civiles como nosotros
no quieren la guerra pero se alegraron
tras la explosión en el puente de crimea
hace una semana que afirmó haber
liberado varios miles de kilómetros
cuadrados de territorio y casi 1500
localidades principalmente en los
territorios de Don Bass gerson y harkin